Влітку ми мріяли разом бути в Херсоні
Мрії збуваються
влітку обов'язково так і буде правда Да
просто героїня не тільки нашої команди
України Тетяна Чорновола яка нещодавно
кілька днів тому на одному напрямків
фронту збила черговий який порахують
танки
з усієї штуки причому це осколкова
фугасно це був хороший ефект проти
особового складу це було Миколая в
принципі звичайно цю статистику деяку
генштаб подає коли там є твій танк
особисто приємно подивитися І от кажу як
хлопцям зразу кажу на наступний ранок
каже будемо дивитися на штамп статистиці
на наступний ранок я встаю да підключаєш
сталінку відкриваю оцю оце картинку
зведення генштабу по втрата хворого така
прихожа до хлопців а вони ще там хто
спить хто не спить така кажу їм хлопці
кажу ми така крута команда ми підбили
50% танків на взяв у фронті вчора
закритих телеканалів 5 прямого через три
місяці відео танка збитого на Миколая
від Тетяни чорнової але є ще одна
проблема я звичайно цим пишаюся але для
вас не найкраща новина
ми стріляли танк в сліпу тобто на тому
відео будемо мало що видно Ти Видно
тільки як відварити самого танка ви
навіть і не побачите чому дуже важкі
погодні умови так знов таки ж вони не
виїжджають стріляти так щоб побачили
розстріляли так а цей танк виїхав про
сітці серед дерев до речі щоб ви
розуміли полювали ми на нього три тижні
от чисто три тижні причому команду на
збиття цього танку нам дала одна бригада
потім бригада помінялося і ми їх підбили
вже під командуванням інших бригади
Причому коли його підбила я зразу
рапортую ці бригаді ваш доказувати ці
бригаді в якій стали але в чому проблема
тобто вони виїжджають да але ж завжди на
інше місце от в принципі спостерігаєш
засікли якесь місце де встале на те
місце Воно виїхали на сусіди навіть його
бачиш а достати не можеш Ну що побачиш
бачиш стрільбу коли танк стріляє ти
бачиш виходи але він там стоїть
наприклад за деревами або дальність не
позволяє ти переходиш на інше місце Він
виїжджає на попередньому і отак от
гасаєш туда-сюда намагаючись його
підловити в нього скільки точок виїзду і
тільки одна точка наприклад Де ти
фронтально його достаєш тобто Ти його
бачиш з боку але він за деревами бо він
виїжджає в просіці тут дерева тут дерева
якщо ти тільки став навпроти Ти можеш
його достати круто сказати Будь ласка
для цивільного населення от е-е що
бухкає весь час ми чули 152 як Наскільки
я розумію по звуку А ми чули сьогодні
фосфорній касеті
і бачите інтернету якби це було Мирне
життя То ми би подумали що це якийсь
феєрверк але от і досі присмак такі
фосфора мабуть щодо цього знову-таки
танку не буду розказала
щось просто блиснуло в тепловізор в тому
місці де ми його чекали тобто нас ми так
стали що два місця де ми їх чекали
нами було досяжено зі стрільби в одному
місці де ми його чекали щось висунуло в
тепловізор але він вас цікавить Я чув що
що розказати певний скажемо про
професійно що я раніше не знала з кимось
тут также працює поділюся ти провізор
блиснуло і пропало я дивлюся так наче
щось з'явилося в просятці ледь-ледь
тобто дерева затіняють м'ячика стоїть
наче щось квадрат не проглядається так
але тепловізор нічого не бачить А що
виявляється там вже холодний попереду
тобто він звідкись недалеко виїжджав
коли він йшов боком в тепловізор щось
блиснуло А коли повернувся передом він
став абсолютно холодний Я знову тебе
дивлюся в тепловізор нічого нема Я знову
дивлюся так очима Та ні то наче щось да
і тут він починає стріляти Звичайно він
почалась стріляти він себе Де маскує але
випускаємо ракету і знов-таки нічого не
видно ракета летить в сліпу а ракета
Завжди коли випускаєш вона сувається в
сторо тобто її треба доводити навіть
якщо б як стоїть вона коли виходить Вона
виходить завжди в сторону вище нижче Ну
де завгодно так тобто треба бачити Куди
її ведеш і тут нічого не видно взагалі
нічого навіть той той скажемо так силует
який мені хоч якось було видно після
ракет вообще пропав ну ракета летить
летить а я така чекаю стрельне він тут
він стріляє він стріляє і я якраз от
розочку виходу вогню наводжу ракету і от
в останній момент вона влітає а якби він
нестерельному вона полетіла в сторону я
не бачила я його просто не бачила тому
от сам як кажуть підняв м'яч від м'яча і
загинеш от він ві- ві- він був Лі нічого
не виключно тому що він стрельнув нас
чи з хлопцями
От коли ти це не слухайте я ж командир
взводу Я вже давно не ношу ракету Блін
це я почала
Сміливі завжди мають щастя
і Тетяна Чорновола